hi this is Kim from Khan Academy today
we're learning more about the takings
Clause of the Fifth Amendment in another
video we'll discuss the other clauses of
the Fifth Amendment those that deal with
self-incrimination and due process of
law but in this video we're
concentrating on just the last few words
of the Fifth Amendment which forbid the
government from taking private property
for public use without just compensation
to learn more about the takings Clause I
sought out the help of two experts
Richard Epstein is the Lawrence a Tisch
professor of law and director of the
classical liberal Institute at NYU Law
he's also a senior fellow at the Hoover
Institution
Edoardo panel there is the Alan R
tesslar professor and Dean of Cornell
Law School so professor Epstein can you
give us a little background just what is
the takings Clause well there's a rule
in constitutional law that the short of
the provision them were difficulty
interpretation and this is a very short
participated petition it says nor shall
private property be taken for public use
without just compensation and the first
thing to understand about the clause is
that it's in the passive voice so it
doesn't tell you who's taking it and
early on since this was part of the Bill
of Rights it was said to apply only to
Congress and not to the states and then
after the Civil War through the
Fourteenth Amendment it was said to
apply to the States so now it applies to
both the states and to the federal
government many constitutions don't have
an explicit property protection clause
but this is a fairly strong norm around
compensating owners of private property
when you essentially commandeer their
property for public purposes and that
and that you know that seems to have
been the motivation and it's you know I
think the clearest reading of it is that
it's a provision of the Constitution
that makes clear that when the federal
government takes your property or when
the states take your property for some
public use that they have to make you
whole by giving you just compensation
private property is a pretty
comprehensive term everybody understands
that it means land and the things you
build on land
they also understand that it tends to
cover channels that is things like books
and baseballs that you happen to own and
wild animals but it's also is much
broader than that it covers all sorts of
intangible rights like patents
copyrights trade secrets these are very
complicated and generally speaking the
government doesn't have any obligation
to create a patent but once it gives you
the pad that just can't take it from you
because the patent after conferred is in
fact now a property right and then it
also may or may not cover all the kinds
of intangibles like goodwill which is
the value associated with the business
knowing that your past customers may
come back to you in the future on the
motives of the framers for including
this talk about things like the
confiscation mostly of personal property
during the Revolutionary War by the
British government that that was
possibly a motivation to make clear that
if you know in future scenarios if the
government wanted to take your property
it would have to you would have to
compensate you I think most historians
don't think there was a real problem
being addressed by this you know problem
of uncompensated taking of property by
colonial governments during during that
period or by the by the state
governments during the Articles of
Confederation the framers wanted a
system of what we call limited
government and so with the takings
clause essentially says is yes we need
your land for a fort and it's really
very important but if we're gonna take
it and use it for a fort that's a public
use we're gonna pay you a compensation
for the fair market value of the land
before the fort was put on and this is
in order to make sure that you can't
pick and choose your victims and it's a
way of assuring government regularity
that's the first second thing is more
economic less apparent at the time of
the framing but pretty apparent today is
if the government can take something and
not pay your compensation it's gonna
overtake so your land is worth a hundred
thousand dollars as a farm but if you're
gonna use it for a fort it's only worth
ten thousand dollars if you don't have
to pay the hundred thousand dollars well
you may take it because you get ten
thousand dollars worth of gain
but if you have to pay the fellow fair
market value of the property interest
taking you won't do it
so essentially what it does is it makes
sure or at least improves the odds that
when the government does take property
what does regulate it will in fact
improve overall social welfare so you
have a political function dealing with
singling out and you have an economic
function dealing with the overall
improvement of government behavior from
an economic point of view okay so say I
had a piece of land and the government
decided that they wanted it for some
purpose what would be the legal process
for the government to go about acquiring
my land varies by state but typically
there's some notice that the government
gives you that it intends to take your
property the government goes to court
and gets an order of condemnation to
take title to the property and then the
often is a requirement that it garden
the government bargain with you about
the value of the property it will tell
you what it thinks the value is the fair
market value is the standard that we use
for just compensation that's the the
value that a willing buyer would pay to
a willing seller for the land
it doesn't include things like your
sentimental value or anything like that
so it's just the market value of the
property there's some back-and-forth you
know through this required bargaining if
the government and the property owner
can't reach an agreement then the
government can go to court and get the
court to specify the value of the
property that we paid in compensation
and then the payment is made and the
deed is transferred and the government
becomes the owner of the property
interesting so the government has gone
through this process to try to acquire
my land what if I'm a real holdout and I
just really don't want the government to
get my land what happens then well you
can litigate the various pieces of this
and again it depends a little bit on the
state law so some states put more
procedural hurdles in the way of the
government other states you know make it
easier for the government but under the
Constitution they're really only two
ways you can resist the taking of your
property through eminent domain one is
by arguing that the use that the
government plans to make of your
property
doesn't count as a legitimate public use
because if Clause says nor shall private
property be taken for public use without
just compensation and that public use
language has been interpreted to be a
limitation on the power of eminent
domain and then you can argue the second
thing you can argue is that what the
government is offering you in terms of
just compensation is not adequate
compensation and you can litigate those
through the courts and that can slow the
process down quite a bit
some states make it easier for the
government by saying well the government
can actually just take title while you
litigate and others make you go you know
you know allow you to stop the the
condemnation process and litigate in
advance but there's there's often what's
called a quick tape procedure which
allows the government to move more more
quickly and put the litigation on the
back end the the public use if it's
found if the used is found not to be
public you what you win is an actual
prohibition on the taking itself right
you keep your property if you win on the
just compensation side all you get is
more money they still take your property
so you mentioned public use what counts
as public use well under the current law
you know any use that generates a public
benefit is really a public use so and
the way the court has put it is anything
the government any purpose the
government can pursue to run the other
means it can pursue through eminent
domain so if you know if the government
wants to create jobs or if the
government wants to beautify or if the
government wants to remove blight all
those things are things that we think
it's legitimate for the government to
try to do if it can do those things it
can do them through the use of the
eminent domain power one thing that
strikes me as interesting is just the
fact that this clause is in the Fifth
Amendment among things like double
jeopardy or self-incrimination so why do
you think the framers included this
particular clause here as opposed to
elsewhere in the bill of rights well
that's a great question to which there's
no obvious answer but the one clause
that is pretty close
it is the due process clause in the
fifth member says nor shall any person
be deprived of life liberty or property
without due process of law so if you
stop with the procedural stuff
somebody's gonna say well how do we know
that the procedures aren't fair and if
it turns out that the government uses a
set of procedures on that don't give you
adequate notice you're always going to
end up short on the amount of
compensation that you're going to
require so bad to see just tend to lead
to bad outcomes which tend to lead to
property being taken at less than full
market value so what happens is is
therefore very close linkage between the
procedures used in under the Due Process
Clause and the substance of protection
that you have undertaken any changes in
the interpretation of the takings Clause
by the supreme court over time well
there's been a huge kind of switch up
and down and let me put it the following
way in the beginning there wasn't much
of anything that was done with respect
to the takings clause the first federal
case to deal with it was called Baron
against Baltimore in 1833 or so and it
just simply said that the clause does
not allow for protection of mr. Baron
against the city of Baltimore because it
only binds the federal government it
doesn't bind the state after the Civil
War two things happen of a real
distinction the first thing is you start
getting comprehensive regulation of the
railroads and the rates they can charge
and then public utilities and the rates
that they can charge and then in 1921
there's a case called block V Hirsch and
it's a very close five-to-four decision
but they sustained on the grounds that
it's a wartime a temporary two years
statute that limits the rents that can
be charged in Washington DC at the end
of the first world war one of the
biggest changes in the interpretation of
the takings Clause was the extension of
the takings Clause to government
situations in which your property was
not appropriated by the government so
what we call the regulatory takings
doctrine which started in the with the
case of Pennsylvania coal ore versus
Mahon in the 1920s and
then has now become much way it was sort
of dormant for a while become much more
active since the nineteen eighties
that's a doctrine that says if the
government regulates your use of
property excessively then the courts can
entreat that in effect as a confiscation
of your property and require the payment
of just compensation that was a pretty
that's maybe the most significant change
in the interpretation of the clause you
know in its history so there continues
to be controversy about the public use
doctrine modern commentators especially
libertarians want a very narrowly drawn
account of public use and disagree with
the breadth of the doctrine as I
described it to you and and so there's a
lot of activism around that there's been
some state law that's been enacted to
try to raise the floor there though the
federal definition of public use is just
the floor and states can go beyond that
and restrict the power of eminent domain
more forcefully if they want to and many
have so we've learned that the takings
Clause of the Fifth Amendment prevents
both federal and state governments from
taking private property for public use
without just compensation but there are
a lot of questions about what counts as
private property public use or just
compensation in recent years debate or
for the takings Clause has centered on
whether government regulations about how
a private individual can use land also
constitute a form of confiscation and
the extent of acceptable public uses for
which the government can seize property
to learn more about the fifth amendment
visit the National Constitution Center's
interactive Constitution and Khan
Academy's resources on US government and
politics